Speaker 1: Let's talk now about 2024 Republican
presidential candidate Chris Christie.
The reason I talk about Chris Christie is
not because all of a sudden I'm a Republican.
not because I think he's going to win the
Republican nomination.
I will get to that in a moment.
The reason I talk about Chris Christie is
because the contrast between a Republican
who is connected to the real world, but whom
I disagree with on policy and the rest of
these clowns could not be a starker contrast
today.
Chris Christie appeared on Fox News a couple
of days ago and it is remarkable.
Yes, he's pounding Trump.
He's going after Trump, he's ridiculing Trump.
He's saying things about Trump that the rest
of them aren't willing to say.
But it is remarkable how different his entire
demeanor and approach is to this Republican
primary.
He's almost certainly not going to win.
And we'll talk about that in a moment.
But listen to Christie say things that are
not controversial and say them in a way that
they all should be saying them, but nobody's
willing to do it other than Chris Christie.
Speaker 2: But my view is he's let us down,
Didn't build the wall.
Mexico didn't pay for it.
Didn't repeal and replace Obamacare.
He said he would say he's going to balance
the budget.
He didn't.
And you mentioned debates.
Look, we should have debates and everyone
should be at the debates and folks should
go to Chris Christie dot com donate and make
sure I'm on the stage.
But Donald Trump should be on that stage,
too.
If you want the Republican nomination, the
Republican voters have the right to see us
right in those cameras and have us compare
and then let them choose.
And American people are good at that.
And we live, but they need all the information
and that's what we want to give them.
The fact is, if you put much stock into the
polling, what I put, that's what it is today.
You know, you're what they ask you, how they
ask those questions.
You would call by pollster, they say, if the
election were held today.
Well, if the election were held today, I'd
be shocked because the first election is not
going to be in January in Iowa.
January of 2024.
We're six, seven months away from that now.
So let's run a campaign.
I don't think we crown kings in America.
You got to work for it.
And Donald Trump needs to work for this nominee,
become the nominee.
Do you all become friends again?
Does he offer you a cabinet post again?
Do you all clean this up and he becomes the
nominee?
I don't think so.
I think, you know, some of the some of the
stuff he's called me over the last few months,
I don't think that's going to happen.
And and that's sad.
But it is the truth of the matter and it's
his doing.
But you're not closing the door to voting
for him.
I'm no, I'm saying I can't support him.
I won't vote.
I can't support either one of them, not Biden
or Trump, because they're not competent and
qualified to be president for different reasons.
Joe Biden, predominantly because of his age
and what we see on TV.
And Donald Trump because I don't believe he
can win.
Lawrence.
You know, when you're under this much criminal
scrutiny and the conduct, by the way, that
he's engaged in taking those documents, keeping
him in his home, making sure that his own
lawyers didn't get to see all of them not
telling the truth to the Justice Department
when they wanted those documents back and
now saying that what he was saying on the
tape when his waiver on document while I was
lying then.
Well, I think Mama Jones and I know my mom
would say the same thing, you're lying once.
I'm not going to believe the other time, too.
We need to have someone who's honest, direct
and who can beat the Democrats because I'm
tired of losing Chris.
Speaker 1: All right.
So, listen, this is not remarkable stuff.
What's remarkable is how remarkable, unremarkable
stuff sounds from Chris Christie, because
no one else is willing to say this stuff.
Now, it's not lost on me that I'm sure it's
extremely triggering for Trump to turn on
Fox News, which at one point was extremely
friendly to him, as Trump says.
And now they allow other candidates to express
their views.
It's not even that Fox News is no longer friendly
to Trump.
It's just other candidates have other views
and they think they're better than Trump.
This is not about glorifying Chris Christie
as the moral of whatever Christie stood.
Behind Trump literally and metaphorically
for years and went with all of the stuff.
And now all of a sudden he's willing to say
these things.
But still, it is a good thing to meet MAGA
where they are and many of them are still
watching Fox News.
And that's why it is a great thing to have
Chris Christie saying these things.
It is not good for Trump to have a guy capable
of coherent and provocative soundbites attacking
Trump.
It's not good for Trump.
Will it make a difference?
I don't know.
And this is where I get to.
Okay.
I want to have this conversation with you
as well.
People write to me.
And I see the comments and they say, David,
you loser, Chris Christie is not going to
win.
I never said Chris Christie was going to win.
I'm not supporting Chris Christie.
It's almost like just because I recognize
that Chris Christie's the only sane Republican
running a normal campaign, I want him to win.
And therefore, if he loses, you've defeated
me.
I'm not voting for any of these people.
But it is crystal clear, crystal clear that
if you said one of these Republicans is going
to be the next president, it's not going to
be Biden.
Who do you go with?
It is obvious.
I go with Chris Christie.
Now, some people will write in and say, David,
how are you defending Christie, who's so corrupt?
I'm not defending Christie.
What I'm telling you is he's the only candidate
willing to tell the truth about Trump, who's
not playing coy, who isn't angling for either
a VP slot or Trump's MAGA voters, or whatever
the case may be.
Now, he's obviously not going to win as a
result.
Chris Christie went from polling 1% to 2.5%.
Now he's down to 2.4%.
And an average of recent polls, 2.4 is not
super strong.
Okay.
Even if it's more than double where you started.
So there.
It's really an indictment of MAGA that there
is essentially no appetite, no appetite for
just a normal Republican who would do things
they claim to like.
I think Chris Christie would probably try
to lower the taxes of the people Republicans
try to lower taxes for.
And, you know, he said he wanted the wall
built.
He's mad at Trump because Trump didn't build
the wall.
I mean, it's like he would more or less do
the things I thought Republicans wanted and
he has no chance.
It is an incredible indictment of the modern
Republican Party.